damit das wasser hat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft okay so herzlich
willkommen 25 minuten
ich habe mir nach langer überlegung
überlegt ich zeit mein gesicht ja ja ja
ich weiß es ist jetzt zeigt auf seinem
bauch zeigte wochen ein gesicht doch
genau auf jeden fall habe gedacht ich
muss mich nicht mehr vor der kamera
verstecken
die meisten wissen schon wie ich aussehe
und jetzt drehe ich einfach okay sally
ist ein bisschen blöd in kamera auf mich
schaut aber ich bin kein ambitionierter
koch ich bin gezwungen zu kochen weil
meine frau einfach zeit braucht um sich
neue rezepte auszudenken und jetzt muss
ich sie unterstützen da hinten ist aber
nicht meine frau die denkt gerade zeigt
man kann zwar noch zeigen da ist sie
gerade denken ist denkt sie neue rezepte
aus und funktioniert deswegen hab ich
gedacht ich komme hier mit den jungs
zusammen mit marius rechts von mir und
dem tor in front of my irgendwas grid
und deswegen fangen jetzt anzupacken und
zu kochen ganz ganz einfache sachen ich
bin wirklich keine kurve war in der
küche aber das was ich hingekriegt ja
auch hin
und wir machen einfach kochen auf
geringem bildungsniveau okay
normalerweise mit ihr zwei hier kochen
mich da stehen sagt nicht dahinter
aber wir machen kochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau und habe mir gedacht wenn
sie sich rein kamen und vor die kamera
trat da kann ich es auch also bin ich
einfach mal vor der kamera und mache
etwas ist ja die lacht da hinten
okay wir machen ganz ganz einfache
rezepte einfachen rezepte sie meistens
günstig das ist für mich als schwabe
natürlich klasse deswegen zeigt euch was
ihr heute braucht raps oliven öl ich
wusste ob ich hab's oder olivenöl nehmen
habe ich einmal gab's olivenöl genommen
dann haben wir hier eine zwiebel dann
haben wir hier drei kartoffeln ich hab
sogar angezeigt 1 234 nach hat die
reihenfolge machen es ja egal
das habe ich gedacht wie eine kartoffel
habe ich gemerkt das ist eine ziemlich
und einzigen gemacht so dann haben hier
drei eier auch ich habe es auch
nummeriert hier ist auch egal welches
eine zuerst benutzt und dann haben wir
hier wirklich es passt
das ist so ein schinken der ist echt
lecker dann haben wir hier im türkischen
café keese
es ist eine art krise oder sind
weichkäse
aber letztlich war ich schnitzel ist der
einschnitt lesen ist genau diese ist
käse auf jemanden nicht richtig lecker
da ist nicht zuhört sich aber auch nicht
sofort deswegen machen uns so dass sally
diese diese peinlichkeit zu ersparen
dass ich hier kochen habe ich diesmal
wirklich alles hin gerichtet ist jetzt
dritte mal ist mein drittes video und
ich freue mich alle schon regeln
ein viertes oder für das video schon
egal ob wir erstmal alles hin gerichtet
ist kann nichts falsch laufen geht nicht
alles sauber noch noch nicht alles
sauber und außerdem genau das heißt 55
minuten krieg weil ich einfach zu viel
aber kann das sei okay aber wir fangen
jetzt an
so jetzt nehme ich diese schneidet das
ist wundervoll schneidebrett und fangen
an mit mit weißwein gleich an mit den
kartoffeln und zwar mit der einst war
ich an eine kartoffel die freiheit zu
stehlen
und wie gesagt ich mache das wirklich
für meine frau weil meine frau mir so
wichtig ist auf jeden fall versuchen
trotzdem gewisse seriosität hier rein zu
bringen
ich möchte natürlich nicht blamieren und
jetzt schauen wir auch kinder zu und
jetzt stelle ich einfach diese kartoffel
so ich lege es einfach hin
doch nur zwei wie gesagt die reihenfolge
der kartoffel ist völlig egal
ihr könnt auch selbst mit drei anfangen
und dann runter arbeiten von zwei auf
eins aber ja das geht nach rückwärts
zählen kann
wie gesagt kochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau also ich hab schon bei
einem anderen video vermittelt dass
viele männer sich nach meinen videos
einen herzog haben und gekocht haben bin
ich wirklich klasse hat aber nur 3
wahnsinn oder
übrigens ist das feld seiner kartoffeln
die kommen aus frankenthal von dicken
bauern kommen die besten kartoffeln
genau
du bist mein assistent was soll ich tun
was man als nächstes von es als nächstes
tun und die kartoffelwürfel nachdem ihr
dass ihr weg gebracht haben
zack aufgeräumt wahnsinn
jetzt kommen die nächsten hier das ist
ein alligator das ding jetzt habe ich
einen fehler nicht machen ist ein
letztes mal gemacht und zwar tut mir die
kartoffel erst halbieren das ist nachher
würfel gibt so aber sind trotzdem
stifter geworden aber das ist egal warum
habe ich nicht gleich gewürfelt bisher
das habe ich dinge gewürfelt
genau das ist schon mal da sind ich muss
natürlich aber wo es von meiner frau
wissen jetzt nehme ich die andere
kartoffel und natürlich auch hier ein
deswegen mal halbiert hat ein bisschen
was mit geometrie zu tun müsst ihr nicht
verstehen macht es einfach so wie ich
auch gemacht habe
zack zack wahnsinn oder
ich habe die kartoffel gestiftet
eigentlich hätten sie gewürfelt zahlen
müssen aber es macht nichts aus das ist
der kater will mich ganz egal was ich
finde das olivenöl und zwar nur lieben
rapsöl ist ein gesundes hole ich mir das
damit können ja auch bei hohen
temperaturen
deswegen ein schützen so das machen wir
jetzt noch einmal den ofen an oder hat
die herdplatte da gehen mir langsam von
stufe 3 von 4
erst langsam erhitzen so das gericht
panne kaputt ich habe schon mehrere
panzer zerstört deswegen darf ich auch
nicht so oft in die küche also bitte
liebe kinder fallen immer langsam
erhitzen und zwar jetzt immer dieses
oliven rapsöl und warten ab ok müssen
war das zimmer und schränke
dazu stellt das schön hin schwenken ein
bisschen die panne
jetzt kam noch ein bisschen schneller
hoch gehen es gebe auch sechs auf boost
jetzt hauptsächlich waren raus sagt
jetzt sind wir diese kartoffeln und tun
die kartoffeln anbraten sagt okay stell
dir vor das verläuft jetzt irgendwie und
[Applaus]
384 anbraten
normalerweise werden sie gewillt gewesen
aber ich war in geometrie molinas
deswegen jetzt immer noch ein paar
anwender musste sie brauchen nen ein ass
und es darf nicht so rauchen dann habt
ihr schon zu heiß gemacht ach gott und
zwar soll tauchen das tut irgendwelches
stoffe freisetzen nicht gesund sind hart
so dass man es noch schön zur seite
den brauche ich noch wir jetzt machen
weiter mit der zwiebel hier natürlich
ist auch schön
[Musik]
jetzt nur die zwiebel auch würfeln und
zwar ist es ganz einfach das auch
wirklich würfe gibt wie ich einmal
halbieren
ein viertel
so jetzt habe sie geschüttelt zwar hier
ein fast perfekter hier noch anbraten
dir schön anbraten bis sie durch sind in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal den
käse schneiden
das ist schmückt ist ja genau
in der schwersten zeit schließt
zwischenzeit schnitt sich schneiden käse
wahnsinn so mitten durch habe ich auch
so ein gerät zum käse schneiden sind
[Musik]
wie gesagt und so plant die kartoffel
umso schneller sind sie durch ich warte
jetzt einfach noch zwei drei minuten und
in der zwischenzeit streicht die eier
genau das war hier bei 1 die reihenfolge
ist wirklich egal sein
pro kartoffel im dunkel verein ein
das sieht gut aus das heißt schon mal
gemacht
wahnsinn oder und jetzt kommt sie auf
die technik an ihr klingt so schlagen
oder so schlagen die machen meistens
rechts runden jetzt haben wir hier ein
bisschen salz genau aber nicht zu viel
weil nachher das passt immer was ich ein
typ der ich schon ziemlich wird es genug
es war auch jetzt mehr salz also mehr
salz gut gehen er war sauer ist dort
dauert sie mit langem anbraten
das ist ein bisschen hoch wie gesagt
beim kochen versuchen das nicht raucht
denn es braucht dann rauch zahlen
natürlich passt ein fehler gemacht hast
gemerkt einen fehler gemacht
ich muss doch erst klein machen ein tipp
für die leute die keine ahnung haben
einen deckel drauf machen so der passt
dann auch nicht drauf aber so während
die kartoffel hier anbraten oder dünsten
was auch immer tue ich jetzt keine ziel
mit rein geben das weiß nur es war ein
fehler
egal alles waren die musiker doch klein
macht jetzt eine ziemlich reingemacht
umziehen kann ja die zusammen manchen ja
egal wir versuchen das beste rauszuholen
aus dem rezept
kannst du eigentlich so die fahne zu
schwenken so cool ja klar natürlich erst
aufkommen
[Musik]
so jetzt nur die rein die kartoffeln
zack zack
es ist jetzt nur eine problemlösung also
jetzt von anfang an hätte das anders
machen sollen
aber ich zeige und einfach dass ich
nicht aufgebe und weiterkämpfen so jetzt
musst du aufpassen hier beim top und
jetzt komm ich einfach ob jedes gepresst
kriege ich meine fünfte schon vorbei
meinte wir sind wir weiter wir müssen
mal im zweiten teil machen hat probiert
um netz zu machen mit kartoffeln beim
kochen durch die ein fehler nicht machen
ich habe es nur gezeigt ein ich weiß wie
es geht ich wollte nur zeigen wir müssen
nicht machen weil ich euch vor den
fehlern behüten möchte so wir waren auch
im zweiten teil morath macht ein omelett
aber ihr müsst einfach geduldig sein
so jetzt haben wir es hier drin und tun
das noch mal mit mir zusammen zusammen
machen der 1
das sind ja als emulgator das wird jetzt
eine homogene masse die panne wieder
oliven rapsöl gemisch möchten ja was für
unsere gesundheit tun
okay jetzt kann man das hier machen die
nummer heißt gehen auf stufe vier
langsam hochdienen heißt jetzt noch
folgendes und zwar jetzt schon ein
bisschen her drauf jetzt gehen wir hoch
ihr seht jetzt habe ich ein richtig
plattform gemacht jetzt geht auch auf 7
das ist richtig schön an prägt und dann
tue ich hier nicht mal was ich jetzt
mache ist auch cool natürlich dann
gleich eine eine geschichte über ein die
paz zu matschig ist schon ganz ganz ganz
leckere türkische käse da kommt aus käse
käse schinken ist ein ganz leckere
schinken mein zeug man aufpassen werde
das gegessen habt dann schwitzt er nach
etwas anbrennt wir machen noch nicht bis
es anbrennt wir warten bis es fest ist
ja jetzt bringst du an und jetzt nämlich
diesen leckeren passte mag so und den
tue ich jetzt richtig lecker drüber zack
zack
das ist nachher so lecker
es ist immer toll eine richtige freundin
die sagen dann die wahrheit ins gesicht
das machen wir nochmal eine käse schicht
darüber richtig lecker wahnsinn so jetzt
aufgabe und ein halbes kilo schinken
drauf gehabt und jetzt machen wir
nochmal hier bisschen käse darüber jetzt
warten wir einfach ein bisschen ab jetzt
schmilzt auch der käse das alles
verbindet sich wird zu einem festen
klumpen und trennt den unternehmen
einfach um und man nochmal eine schicht
darüber wahnsinn mit absoluter wahnsinn
jetzt muss ich den nächsten schritt
machen und zwar jetzt kommt die schicht
obendrüber das alles wieder zusammen
hält ihr seht ihr habt ein bisschen zu
wenig kartoffeln genommen das heißt ich
konnte auf die pannen größe an
wo viel zu wenig noch zwei kartoffeln
mehr nehmen müssen aber das hat eine
panne geschuldet
[Musik]
ich muss zugeben dass das ding ist
schwieriger als gedacht dieses amulett
war schwieriger als gedacht hab ich den
prozess ist richtig wundervoll schmecken
die ppp mühe gegeben und jetzt gespannt
was meine frau dazu sagen okay ich bin
zwar anderen fehlt hat lesen einzel ist
ein röstaromen das sind alles nur
röstaromen das ist wirklich lecker ok
mein anspruch war es ähnlich das gesund
zu machen
wir sind ein riesen team du probierst
ist als allererstes und wenn dir nix
passiert dachte mal ausprobieren er ist
ein fotograf den brauchen wir noch
aber die muss auch ehrlich sein ganzer
events ihnen schmecken sagt lieber so
wie du immer ja und dann sagst sei
ehrlich wenn es nicht schmeckt dann egal
ich versuche es nicht zu verunstalten
das muss cool schmecken ich glaube bis
auf dem käse alles um gesund ich glaube
es gesund ist die beschichtung der theke
und wandel
warum hast du jetzt mal ehrlich nicht
ehrlich cool lecker ehrlich jetzt ja so
wie sie ist ja genau das stück gewesen
was du gasträumen boden gefallen ist
echt lecker er ist es schön würzig und
voll creme ich weiß ja nicht wie du die
kartoffeln kleinen gemacht hat weil ich
hab's nicht gesehen ich habe da hinten
bisschen rezepte geschrieben echt gut
also ich auch sagen warnt ganz ehrlich
ich bin selber begeistert ich bin
begeistert wenn das waschbecken später
wieder
ich hab's auch geräumt das ist nicht
auch über einem kleinen kind was sich
hinter der tafel verstecken so der
kleine dicke geht voraus waschbecken
jetzt immer gar nicht aber ich bin es
wirklich wahnsinnig macht es um mich
nach macht sie ein bisschen anders als
ich mach's besser
und wie soll ich sagen zum beispiel
zuerst an die kartoffel vielleicht noch
kleiner zu machen und dann würde ich die
die zwiebel erst rein machen nachdem die
kartoffeln gestampft hat was ist jetzt
schon wieder was hab ich gemacht wieder
okay also richtig lecker das ding macht
echt cool ich bin ich begeistert mach
das bitte nach und wir sehen uns auf
jeden fall das nächste mal
ich hoffe ich habe eure geschmacksnerven
nicht zu überstrapazieren und wir sehen
uns noch mal kommentiert auf jeden fall
abonniert diesen kanal und wenn ihr noch
mehr videos von mir sehen wollt dann
schreibt spd darunter
wenn nämlich hätten wollt dann tut es
ist alles da machts gut vielen dank
damit jetzt alle
[Applaus]
okay das nächste mal butterbrot es wird
auch nicht gedacht okay ich nicht mehr
weitermachen und dann kann das 1
[Musik]
also ist es nicht perfekt aber die
kamera nicht aber es schmeckt wirklich
wirklich richtig lecker ich würde
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr setzen
könnte noch ein bisschen aber ist
geschmackssache aber niemals gedacht das
ist so lecker schmeckt also ich hab
nicht erwartet und bin natürlich jetzt
richtig freuen
ich hoffe dass jetzt viele männer dazu
animiert habe dies auch zu machen
das wären wir nicht diesen
herzensangelegenheit alles klar
bis dahin tschüss macht's besser